illegale partys aggressive stimmung die
polizei kritisiert den umgang mit corona
regeln gegen lukaschenko für demokratie
wieder ziehen zehntausende durch belarus
und einen matchball und ein strahlender
sieger alexander zverev gewinnt das
erste atp turnier in köln
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg den abend schön dass sie
dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann für
den sport ein schirm über haben doch von
mir im kampf gegen die steigenden corona
zahlen komme es auf jeden einzelnen an
so auch heute wieder der appell aus der
politik die polizeigewerkschaft meldet
trotz aller akzeptanz der chor ohne
regeln beginne die stimmung aggressiver
zu werden antwortet kurschilgen hat
details corona einsatz der polizei auf
der hamburger reeperbahn und 90
feierwütige haben im keller dieser disco
eine illegale party gefeiert mit viel
alkohol und wenig abstand als die
polizei die veranstaltung auflösen will
verbarrikadieren sich die partygäste in
der disco wollen weiter feiern
auch in düsseldorf haben die
einsatzkräfte alle hände voll zu tun
hier während sich maskenträger gegen
masken muffel
die stimmung wird aggressiver der
einsatz für den beamten gefährlicher
ansteckungsgefahr ausgesetzt ist und
dass diese ansteckungsgefahr eben über
ignoranten auch noch provoziert wird in
dem gebügelt wird angespuckt wird und
angehustet wird das ist natürlich eine
zusätzliche belastung und die gefahr
wird immer größer denn die
infektionszahlen steigen weiter in den
letzten 24 stunden haben sich 5587
menschen neu angesteckt vor einer woche
lag der wert bei 3483 wir stehen derzeit
an einem wendepunkt wenn wir in den
nächsten zwei wochen die kurve nicht
bekommen dann laufen wir in ein
exponentielles wachstum hinein was sehr
schwer zu beherrschen sein wird dann
fürchte ich tatsächlich dass wir doch
lokal zumindest wieder mit schatton
maßnahmen reagieren müssen
ein zweiter lockdown muss auf jeden fall
verhindert werden
deshalb brauchen wir eine andere
strategie von der maske über die
verstärkung des gesundheitsdienstes bis
hin zu einer umfassenden test strategie
muss alles unternommen werden damit ein
zweiter stillstand ausgeschlossen wird
und das wird wohl nur klappen wenn sich
die allermeisten an die regeln halten
und dann hätte auch die polizei auf den
partymeilen wie hier in
burg wohl weniger zu tun der deutsche
städtetag fordert das schnell
bundeswehrsoldaten und andere helfer zur
verfügung stehen müssten um die kontakte
von corona infizierten nachzuverfolgen
er rechne mit einem fünfstelligen
personalbedarf sagte
hauptgeschäftsführer helmut dedy der
rheinischen post
um das kanzleramt geht von einem bedarf
von mehr als 10.000 weiteren helfern aus
frankreich italien die niederlande viele
europäische länder melden so viele neue
infektionen wie nie und ziehen
konsequenzen in slowenien hat das
gesundheitsamt aufgegeben die kontakte
positiv getestet dazu verfolgen es sind
zu viele
die schweiz verschärft ihre masken
pflicht um spontane partys zu verhindern
dürfen sich draussen nicht mehr als 15
menschen treffen und in paris und
anderen französischen städten gilt seit
diesem wochenende eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre
neben corona wird die franzosen das
attentat vom freitag auf ein
geschichtslehrer war auf offener straße
enthauptet worden
trotz des verbots von
großveranstaltungen kamen wir hier in
paris tausende zusammen um samuel partie
zu gedenken
ein 18-jähriger russisch
tschetschenischer herkunft hatte ihn
unweit seiner schule getötet und war
danach von der polizei erschossen worden
die partie hatte in seinem unterricht
zum thema meinungsfreiheit
mohammed-karikaturen gezeigt auch in
belarus gab es heute wieder
demonstrationen wie jeden sonntag
zehntausende treibt der prozess protest
immer wieder auf die straße seit anfang
august seit der umstrittenen wiederwahl
von machthaber lukaschenko die polizei
hatte den demonstranten mit dem einsatz
von schusswaffen gedroht trotzdem ließen
sich die menschen auch heute nicht
einschüchtern
christian sein berichtet es lebe seit
zehn wochen hallt der ruf der
demonstranten jetzt schon durch die
straßen in verschiedenen städten in
belarus so auch heute wieder wie hier in
der hauptstadt minsk
zehntausende haben sich wieder auf den
weg gemacht und sie protestieren
friedlich
immer wieder ist der internet empfang
gestört die menschen trotzten dem
protest verbot dass lukaschenko system
hatte damit gedroht scharf auf
demonstranten zu schießen
gemeinsam gegen lukaschenko und die
eigene angst die angst auf die straße zu
gehen ist immer da aber wenn wir viele
sind dann löst sich das auch weil wir
rausgehen um gerechtigkeit in unserem
land zu bekommen
schon gestern hatten die
sicherheitskräfte wieder jagd auf
friedliche demonstrantinnen und
demonstranten gemacht es gab rund 60
festnahmen am protest samstag an dem
traditionell vor allem die mutigen bälle
russischen frauen ihren protest zeigen
gegen präsident lukaschenko die von
manchen befürchtete gewalteskalation
heute blieb aus der belarussische start
ist ein terroristischer start und all
die die das eigene volk mit waffen
bedrohen müssen vor gericht
verhaftungen einschüchterungen prügelnde
polizisten und folter in den
gefängnissen haben die
demokratiebewegung nicht zum schweigen
gebracht das belarussische
innenministerium spricht von 100
festnahmen heute aber diese menschen
werden nicht müde für veränderungen
ihrer heimat weiter auf die straße zu
gehen
[Applaus]
demokratiebewegung auch in thailand
trotz versammlungsverbot haben dort
wieder tausende demonstriert sie fordern
den rücktritt der militärregierung und
eine debatte über die rolle der
monarchie im land immer wieder werden
bei den friedlichen protesten anführer
der demokratiebewegung inhaftiert er hat
die welt verändert so hieß es heute in
der laudatio über den neuen
friedenspreisträger des deutschen
buchhandels am matthias henn ist sein
name ein weltberühmter indischer
wirtschaftswissenschaftler und philosoph
der 86-jährige forscht seit jahrzehnten
über die ursachen von hunger und armut
und die folgen der globalisierung vor 22
jahren bekam er als erster asiate den
wirtschaftsnobelpreis susanna santina
die korona krise hatte deutliche
auswirkungen auf die verleihung des
friedenspreis
kaum publikum ein preisträger der
zugeschaltet wird und ein laudator der
ersetzt werden musste weil er in
quarantäne ist die rede von
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
übernahm der schauspieler burghart
klaußner wären heute einen menschen der
wie kein anderer verbunden ist mit der
idee der globalen gerechtigkeit der
preisträger matthias enders posten
zugeschaltet wo der
wirtschaftswissenschaftler seit 2004 als
professor an der harvard universität
lehrt in seiner heimat indien wurde er
schon als kind zeuge von großer armut
und einer hungersnot die sein
forscherleben entscheiden trägt wie
erlangt man soziale gerechtigkeit dieser
frage gibt es einen ein leben lang nach
der heute 86 jährige warnte in seiner
dankesrede vor repressiven tendenzen in
immer mehr starten
leider gehört die erhebliche
einschränkung der meinungsfreiheit nicht
der vergangenheit an
und es gibt immer mehr länder in denen
und chlorid ehre entwicklungen die
freiheit zu widersprechen schwieriger
praktizieren lassen
matthias senn habe sich als vordenker
seit jahrzehnten mit fragen der globalen
gerechtigkeit auseinander gesetzt heißt
es in der begründung des stiftungsrates
seine arbeiten seien heute so relevant
wie nie zuvor
der friedenspreis ist übrigens mit
25.000 euro dotiert und jetzt sind wir
beim sport da freut man sich beim ersten
atp turnier in tennisturnieren köln über
einen deutschen sieger alexander zverev
der hat damit das dutzend vollgemacht
der zwölfte titel seiner profikarriere
der weltranglisten siebte gewann das
finale souverän gegen den kanadier felix
so scheer alias im 62 36 23 sein erster
turniersieg seit fast anderthalb jahren
zum dritten mal überhaupt stimmt
alexander zverev den siegerpokal eines
profi turniers in deutschland in die
luft und das nach einem durchweg
souveränen auftritt im finale von köln
gegen die einstige nummer zwei der
junioren weltrangliste glänzt
deutschlands nummer eins zum einen mit
mutiger spielweise zum anderen mit
konstanz und dominanz von der grundlinie
der lohn ist nach diesem fehler von
felix alias
das 6 zu 3 und 6 zu 3 nach einer stunde
und 19 minuten und die chance auf einen
weiteren triumph in deutschland gibt es
für zverev schon in der kommenden woche
beim nächsten turnier an gleicher stelle
von morgen an in köln
im ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball-bundesliga trennten sich köln
und frankfurt unentschieden eins zu eins
am vierten spieltag der erste
punktgewinn der domstädter und letzter
radsport klassiker des jahres die
flandern-rundfahrt und die gewann der
niederländer martijn van der poel ein
anderer top favorit der kam nicht ins
ziel
der weltmeister am boden julia aller
phillipe einer von drei großen favoriten
die sich bei der flandern-rundfahrt
abgesetzt hatten kollision mit einem
begleitmotorrad der franzose muss seine
hoffnungen auf einen sieg begraben
die top favorisierten baut van aart und
mathieu van der pol fahren ihren
verfolgern an den vielen steilen
anstiegen immer weiter davon nach 244
kilometern entscheiden nur zentimeter
zwischen den beiden stars weniger als
ein halbes vorderrad zu gunsten von
panda po in der verfolgergruppe john
degenkolb als bester deutscher neunter
mathieu van de pol aus den niederlanden
feiert seinen größten karriereerfolg das
was von mir
das wetter bleibt durchwachsen morgen in
der nordhälfte dichte wolken vereinzelt
mit regen im südwesten und süden nach
nebelauflösung mehr sonne höchstwerte 8
bis 15 grad
das war es von uns um viertel vor zehn
begrüßt sie claus kleber im
heute-journal wir sagen tschüss bis
morgen wenn sie mögen wünschen ihnen
noch einen unbeschwerten sonntagabend
und geben ab zu theo koll nach